]
>> Greg: YES!
YES.
HAPPY THURSDAY, EVERYBODY!
THE SANCTUARY OF LIGHTS
CONTINUE.
THEY ARE THE ONLY FLIGHTS THAT
ARE ON TIME.
LAST NIGHT FLORIDA
GOVERNOR STEVE DeSANTIS
TOTHE PROGRESSIVE PARADIGM KNOWN
AS MARTHA'S VINEYARD WHICH MAKES
SENSE.
7-YARD
IT'S A VINEYARD AND THOSE GRAPE.
I ASSUME THERE IS GOING TO BE
PLENTY OF WORK ON A VINEYARD.
BUT I WOULDN'T KNOW.
I'M NOT ALLOWED THERE.
NOT SINCE BARACK'S BIRTHDAY
PARTY.
SHOULD HAVE SEEN HIS FACE WHEN I
JUMPED OUT OF THE CAKE.
THE G STRING WAS A LITTLE BIT
TOO MUCH.
AND I WAS WEARING ONE TOO.
THE COVERAGE HAS BEEN HYSTERICAL
AS IF SENDING MIGRANTS FROM A
SWELTERING PART OF TEXAS TO THE
MOST LUXURIOUS SPOT IN AMERICA
HOSTS OF OBAMA, LARRY DAVID,
JOHN KERRY, IS SOMEHOW CRUEL AND
INHUMANE PUNISHMENT.
BUT MAYBE IT IS CRUEL.
YOU KNOW WHO ALSO LIVES THERE?
JAMES TAYLOR.
I KNOW.
I WONDER IF HE HAS A COMMENT.
>> ♪♪ YOU ARE GOING TO LOVE ♪
♪ MARTHA'S VINEYARD MAMA I'D
COME JOIN YOU ♪
♪ BUT MY LEGS ARE INJURED ♪
♪ LARRY DAVID LIVES HERE ♪
♪ AND MEG RYAN TOO ♪
♪ OBAMA LOVES IT ♪
♪ AND SO WILL YOU ♪
♪ BY THE WAY WHAT HAPPENED TO
MEG RYAN ♪
♪ MARTHA'S VINEYARD ♪
♪ IT'S AN ISLAND ♪♪
>> Greg: IT'S AN ISLAND!
EXCELLENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
EVERY LIBERAL CELEBRITY FANCIES
THEMSELVES A SANCTUARY CITY
SUPPORTER, WHY SHOULDN'T THEY
MINGLE WITH THE MIGRANTS THEY
CHAMPION FROM AFAR.
IT'S PRETTY RICH HOW THE MEDIA
REFUSED TO COVER THE BORDER
CRISIS AS LONG AS IT AFFECTED
TEXAS OR FLORIDA BECAUSE WHO
CARES?
NOW THE RESPONSIBILITY HAS BEEN
SHARED BY FORCE, THEY ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED.
LISTEN TO THESE [BLEEP].
>> I THINK THIS IS POLITICAL
THEATER.
>> TREATING PEOPLE LIKE
POLITICAL PAWNS.
>> USING MIGRANTS AS BONDS.
>> ANOTHER DISGUSTING AND VILE
MOVES.
>> THESE ARE CHILDREN AND OLDER
PEOPLE.
WE CAN WORK IT OUT BUT IF YOU
ARE GOING TO BE A BONEHEAD, WHO
WANTS TO PLAY WITH YOU?
>> Greg: WHO WANTS TO PLAY
WITH YOU!
THEY CALL THIS INHUMANE AFTER
IGNORING THE MIGRANT DROWNINGS,
MULTIPLE DEATHS IN SMUGGLERS'
TRUCKS.
OVERDOSES FROM FENTANYL COMING
OVER OUR BORDER.
SAVE YOUR OUTRAGE YOU GARGANTUAN
GAS BAGS FOR YOU ARE WORRIED
ABOUT LOSING THE CHEAP LABOR
THAT TRIMS YOUR HEDGES AND YOUR
BIKINI AREA.
I WAS THINKING ABOUT CHARLIE
CRIST.
VERY CLEAN DOWN THERE.
YES!
I AM REFERRING TO ALL OF THOSE
PEOPLE IN D.C. AND NEW YORK WHO
ARE BEATING THEIR CHESTS WHEN
TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT SAYING THEY
WERE SO PROUD TO BE SANCTUARY
JURISDICTIONS.
RIGHT, RON?
>> ALL THOSE PEOPLE IN D.C. AND
NEW YORK WERE BEATING THEIR
CHEST WINS ME IF I WAS PRESIDENT
SAYING THEY WERE SO PROUD TO BE
CENTURY JURISDICTIONS, SAYING
HOW BAD IT WAS BEING A SECURE
BORDER.
THE MINUTE EVEN A SMALL FRACTION
OF WHAT THOSE BORDER TOWNS DEAL
WITH EVERYDAY IS BROUGHT TO
THEIR FRONT DOOR, THEY ALL OF A
SUDDEN GO BERSERK AND THEY ARE
SO UPSET THIS IS HAPPENING AND
IT JUST SHOWS YOU THERE VIRTUE
SIGNALING AS A FRAUD.
>> Greg: I'M PRETTY SURE THE
MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
WE ARE NOT A SANCTUARY STATE.
>> OUR MESSAGE IS WE ARE NOT A
SANCTUARY STATE.
THERE ARE SOME CENTURY
JURISDICTIONS AND THAT WOULD BE
BETTER.
WHAT WOULD BE THE BEST IS FOR
BIDEN TO DO HIS JOB AND SECURE
THE BORDER.
>> Greg: YOU'RE ONLY ONLY
ALLOWED TO APPLAUD ME.
HE CAN'T HEAR YOU.
THAT WAS TAPE.
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE TO DO ALL
THIS OF THE GOVERNMENT WOULD
ACTUALLY ENFORCE THE LAWS.
AREN'T THEY SUPPORTING POLICIES
THAT ARE FRANKLY INDEFENSIBLE?
>> THEY ARE SUPPORTING POLICIES
THAT ARE FRANKLY INDEFENSIBLE.
IT'S NOT DEFENSIBLE FOR A
SUPERPOWER TO NOT HAVE ANY
CONTROL OVER THE TERRITORY OF
ITS COUNTRY.
OVER THE BORDERS OF ITS COUNTRY.
B-1 THE LOGIC IS SIMPLE.
STATES THAT HAVE INCENTIVIZED
LEGAL
SHOULD BE MADE TO FEEL THE
IMPACT OF THEIR OWN ACTIONS.
GIVEN THAT THEY PRORATED
THEMSELVES AS SANCTUARY STATES,
THEY SHOULD BE OVERJOYED THEY BE
ABLE TO BETTER CARE FOR THE
MIGRANTS THAN THESE EVIL BORDER
STATES.
IT'S PERFECT.
MOCK BORDER STATES WERE
COMPLAINING ABOUT THE PROBLEM?
WHY NOT YOU TRY BEING A BORDER
STATE FOR A WILD PAIR BORDER
STATE DEAL WITH MILLIONS OF
I'M SURE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
ON TOP OF THAT.
>> DOES THE WHITE HOUSE STAND BY
THOSE COMMENTS IN THE BORDER?
>> WE'LL BE STANDBY AS WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE FOLLOW THE PROCESS
THAT HAS BEEN PUT FORTH.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE HISTORIC
FUNDING TO DO JUST THAT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT...
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE FOLKS WE
ENCOUNTER AT THE BORDER BE
REMOVED OR EXPELLED.
>> Greg: THAT SOUNDS LIKE ME
WHEN DANA CAUGHT ME TRYING ON
HER LEGGINGS.
DON'T LEAVE YOUR BEDROOM WINDOW
OPEN!
BUT MAYBE NEEDS THE KAMALA
TREATMENT.
>> WE ARE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN TO MAKE SURE THAT WE FOLLOW
THE PROCESS THAT WE HAVE
HISTORIC FUNDING TO DO JUST
THAT.
TO MAKE SURE THAT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE FOLKS WE ENCOUNTER AT
THE BORDER BE REMOVED.
>> Greg: BONGOS.
SAVE IT FOR LATER.
GIVE SOME OF THAT TO
JIMMY KIMMEL.
A BORDER STATE IS MAKING A
SANCTUARY STATE WALK THE WALK
WHICH POSES A PROBLEM FOR
CRITICS OF FLORIDA AND TEXAS.
HOW CAN YOU BE
IF YOU FEEL THOSERED STATES AREE
AND YOURS ISN'T?
ISN'T TRANSPORTING MIGRANTS TO
YOUR CITY LIKE CHICAGO AND
PHILLY A TRUE ACT OF CHARITY OR
BIPARTISANSHIP?
UNLESS YOU THINK IT'S COOL TO
SEND THEM THERE.
YOU MIGHT BE RIGHT.
MIGRANTS LEAVE VENEZUELA FOR THE
U.S. ONLY TO REALIZE LIBERAL RUN
CITIES MIGHT BE WORSE.
THEY FIND THAT PHILLY IS JUST
CARACAS WITH CHEESESTEAKS.
CHICAGO IS TIJUANA WITH MORE
GUNFIRE.
AT LEAST UNTIL ONE THEY FIRE THE
GUNS IN THE AIR.
NOT INTO THE BEDROOM.
WHAT ABOUT MARTHA'S VINEYARD?
HOMES ARE HUGE BUT SMALL
FAMILIES LIKE THE OBAMA'S ON A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR HOME ON THE
ISLAND WITH MANY SPARE ROOMS BUT
HE CAN TEMPORARILY HOUSE SOME
MIGRANTS.
BUT NO KIDS CAGES THIS TIME.
THINK ABOUT ALL THE TIMES SAVED,
READY TO SET UP THE TABLE FOR
OBAMA'S NEXT SUPER SPREADER
BIRTHDAY PARTY.
THE NEXT PART?
WHAT IT'S DONE TO THE PHONY
POLITICIANS FOR THE MUNCHKIN
MAYOR FROM CHICAGO CALLED TEXAS
SENDING MIGRANTS TO HER CITY
BOTH RACIST AND UNCHRISTIAN FOR
THIS IS BEFORE SHE HERSELF SENT
MIGRANTS FROM HER CITY TO A
SUBURB.
DOESN'T THIS MAKE HER MORE
UNCHRISTIAN SINCE SHE'D BRAG
ABOUT BEING A SANCTUARY CITY?
YOU CAN'T GET MORE UNCHRISTIAN
THEN SAYING THERE IS ROOM AT THE
INN AND WHEN FOLKS ARRIVE AFTER
A LONG JOURNEY TELLING THEM THAT
THERE IS NO ROOM AT THE INN.
YOU CAN BET THAT SOME OF THOSE
FOLKS ARE NAMED JESUS.
[APPLAUSE]
YES.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUEST.
SHE CAN RAISE HELL AND THE
AVERAGE IQ OF OUR PANEL.
K.T. McFARLAND.
LIKE ALL GREAT WRITERS, PLANS TO
BE FAMOUS AFTER DEATH.
TV WRITER PRODUCER ROB LONG.
SHE IS LIKE A FRUIT FLY FOR A
TINY PERSISTENT AND ALWAYS
TRYING TO DIVE INTO YOUR
CHARDONNAY.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
AND HE CAN LIFT YOUR MOOD AND
THE FOUNDATION OF YOUR HOUSE.
MY MASSIVE SIDEKICK AND NWA
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION TYRUS.
ROB LONG, GREAT TO SEE YOU WITH
YOUR BEARD.
>> MY BEARD IS HAPPY TO BE HERE
TOO.
>> Greg: WHAT I LOVE ABOUT
THIS IS HOW UPSET THE LIBERALS
AND THE DEMS ARE GETTING BECAUSE
IT'S FORCING THEM TO COVER
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
>> IS ALSO NOT NEW.
WHEN I WAS LIVING IN L.A. THE
MAYOR WOULD SEND HOMELESS PEOPLE
TO VEGAS BUT MAYOR BLOOMBERG
SENT PEOPLE TO MIAMI BEACH.
A LONG TRADITION OF SENDING
PEOPLE TO RESORT AREAS, RIGHT?
THIS IS ANOTHER RESORT AREA THEY
ARE SENDING THEM TO.
IT'S NOT UNUSUAL TO DO THIS.
SOMETHING PEOPLE DO ALL THE TIME
FOR THE PROBLEM REALLY IS -- TWO
PROBLEMS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE FROM VENEZUELA.
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR ASYLUM.
VENEZUELA IS A PIT BECAUSE IT'S
RUN BY A SOCIALIST CRACKPOT.
SOCIALIST CRACKPOT THAT A LOT OF
AMERICAN CELEBRITIES AND
POLITICIANS LIKE.
>> HUGO.
>> MY THEORY IS WE SHOULD TAKE
ALL THOSE PEOPLE FROM VENEZUELA,
ALL OF THEM, AND RETURN AN EQUAL
NUMBER OF THE AMERICANS LOVE
VENEZUELA SO MUCH, THEY CAN BE
WHERE THEY WANT TO BE AND WE CAN
HAVE, HAPPY TO BE IN AMERICA
AMERICANS WHO DON'T LIKE THAT
KIND OF GOVERNMENT AND IS HAPPY.
IT SHOULD BE AN EXCHANGE
PROGRAM.
SHOULDN'T BE MIGRANTS.
SEAN PENN AND PEOPLE SHOULD BE
GOING BACK.
>> Greg: A SOCIALIST SWAP!
>> EVERYBODY SHOULD BE WHERE
THEY WANT TO BE.
IF YOU WANT TO BE IN THE LAND OF
FREEDOM AND OPPORTUNITY, A LOT
OF THE CELEBRITIES WANT TO BE IN
THE LAND OF SOCIALISM AND
CRACKPOT POTTERY, LET IT GO.
>> Greg: WHETHER CONSERVATIVE
OR LIBERTARIAN, A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE COMING HERE ARE MORE
CONSERVATIVE THAN WE ARE.
TO THINK THAT THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM, NO, THESE PEOPLE ARE
EISENHOWER REPUBLICANS.
MEANWHILE, OUR GEN Z PEOPLE,
THEY CAN EVEN READ.
JUST MADE THAT UP.
DON'T NOT
>> THEY ARE REAGAN REPUBLICANS.
THEY KNOW EXACT WAY HOW BAD IT
IS BUT WE SHOULD SEND THE REST
OF THEM, THE ENTIRE POLITICAL
SCIENCE FACULTY AT HARVARD
SHOULD GO BACK TO VENEZUELA.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> YOU WENT TO YALE!
>> YEAH, I WENT TO YALE.
>> Greg: THEY ALSO SENT
MIGRANTS TO KAMALA HARRIS' HOUSE
AFTER SHE CLAIMED THE BORDER WAS
SECURED.
THAT'S PRETTY RICH.
>> THE REAL STORY HERE IS
DEFINITELY DOING WITH MEN
CHARITY AND GOBBLEDYGOOK.
THEY ARE GOING TO PUT THEM IN
RED STATES, THEY ARE GOING TO
GIVE THEM CITIZENSHIP, THERE'LL
BE VOTERS VOTERS AND THE
DEMOCRATS WHO ARE TRICKY BUT ARE
NOT VERY SMART, THEY DON'T
REALIZE WHAT IN FACT THEY ARE
DOING IS ASSAULTING THE STATE
WITH REPUBLICAN VOTERS BEAR THEY
ARE PRO-FAMILY, THEY WORK HARD,
THEY ARE SMALL BUSINESS WORKERS
AND OWNERS.
THEY BELIEVE IN ALL THE STUFF
THAT THE STANDARD REPUBLICAN
REAGAN REPUBLICAN BELIEVES IN.
THESE STUPID DEMOCRATS, SO
TRICKY.
THEY ARE JUST BRINGING IN
4 MILLION POTENTIAL REPUBLICAN
VOTERS THEY'VE DONE THE LAST TWO
YEARS?
>> Greg: TYRUS, I'VE NEVER MET
A WOKE MEXICAN, NEVER MET A
WELCOME GUATEMALAN, NEVER MET A
LOCAL VENEZUELAN.
THERE IS NO WOKEISM DOWN THERE.
>> WHEN YOU ARE ESCAPING A THIRD
WORLD COUNTRY, YOU MISSED THE
FIRST WORLD PROBLEMS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
YOU DON'T PARTICIPATE.
SPEAKING THE PARTICIPATE, THIS
IS OFF SUBJECT BUT I HAVE TO
CONGRATULATE YOU.
>> Greg: WHY?
>> FOR EFFECTING THE EMMYS THE
WAY YOU DID.
>> Greg: THANK YOU!
>> WE MADE, MADE IT OUR
PARTICIPATION AWARD.
PHENOMENAL.
NOBODY WOULD TAKE IT.
ENJOY THAT.
>> I WILL.
THANK YOU.
>> THAT'S A FIRST WORLD PROBLEM.
THEY DO NOT LIKE BIG GOVERNMENT.
REALLY.
THEY WILL BE VOTING REPUBLICAN
PEER THE PROBLEM THOUGH IS THOSE
SEEKING ASYLUM, I GET IT.
THE GENERAL CONSENSUS IS OUR
BORDER IS WIDE OPEN AND CROSSING
OVER IT ILLEGALLY IS FINE AND AS
LONG AS THAT'S THE MESSAGE IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER THEY VOTE
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT, THEY ARE
STILL ILLEGAL HERE AND IT'S NOT
FAIR FOR THOSE WHO ARE DOING IT
THE RIGHT WAY.
>> Greg: AMERICANS LIKE TO GO
THINGS REALLY LIKE RISK TAKERS
BUT THEY ALSO LIKE PROCESS.
JUST COME IN PLEASE WAIT IN
LINE.
IN-LINE BUYING TICKETS.
IT MAKES ME VERY VIOLENT
SOMETIMES.
>> AMERICA'S FAVORITE SPORT IS
FOOTBALL.
A LITTLE COMMITTEE MEETING.
AND THEN VIOLENCE.
AND A LITTLE COMMITTEE MEETING
AND VIOLENCE BEAR THAT'S WHERE
WE ARE.
YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE THE MEETING.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
>> Greg: THE DEMOCRATS MASTER
STUNT?
>> IT'S BEING DONE TO PROVE A
POLITICAL POINT.
THEY SAY, YOU WANT TO TAKE CARE
OF THESE PEOPLE COMING HERE THEY
ARE.
IT'S A POLITICAL...
BUT I ALSO THINK IT'S RIDICULOUS
HOW THEY ARE FRAMING A FLIGHT TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AS THE WORST
THING THAT PEOPLE HAVE EVER BEEN
TO.
>> Greg: THEY ARE COMPARING IT
TO THE HOLOCAUST!
>> THEY ARE FLEEING HORRIFIC
CONDITIONS.
THEY BEEN TALKING ABOUT IT THIS
WAY THE ENTIRE TIME AND A LOT OF
IT HAS BEEN OFFENSIVE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE CLUELESS,
HELPLESS VICTIMS OF A BUST.
WHY CAN THEY NOT DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES WHETHER OR NOT TO GET
ON THE BUS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE MIGRANTS
QUESTION MIKE THAT'S RACIST.
THEY ARE GETTING ON THE BUS
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GET ON THE
BUS.
THEY ARE GOING TO MARTHA'S
VINEYARD BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GO
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
YOU CAN CALL IT POLITICAL.
IT IS POLITICAL.
THEY ARE MAKING A POLITICAL
POINT.
THESE PEOPLE AREN'T OUTRAGED AND
UPSET CRYING ON THEIR TRIP TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD BUT IT'S THE
BEST THING THAT'S EVER HAPPENED
TO THEM!
>> IF THEY CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PULL THE CORD TO GET ON THE
BUS.
>> THERE IS A STORY THAT THERE
IS A BUS OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
ON THE WAY TO NEW YORK CITY.
>> IS THERE A NICEST PLACE YOU
CAN MAKE.
>> THE PEOPLE LIVING UP TO THE
CONCEPT OF SANCTUARY ARE THE
SAME PEOPLE THAT THE LEFT HATE
AND THAT'S RELIGIOUS FOLKS.
IT'S THE CHURCHES THAT ARE
SHOWING UPGRADING HIS PEOPLE AND
FINDING THEM FOOD AND WHATEVER.
IT'S NOT LEFT-WINGERS.
IT COU